el ángulo a es circunscrito al círculo y
eso quiere decir que si trazamos los
rayos que forman el ángulo esos rayos
son tangentes al círculo y a partir de
eso nos preguntan cuál es la medida del
ángulo en a te recomiendo que detengas
el vídeo para pensar este problema por
tu cuenta pero una pequeña sugerencia es
que definitivamente tienes que utilizar
que el ángulo a se ha circunscrito muy
bien vamos a resolver el problema
la otra información que nos dan es que
la medida del ángulo inscrito se debe es
de 48 grados y notemos que el ángulo se
debe abre el arco cb este arco de acá
que estoy pintando en color verde
y ese arco se ve también lo abre el
ángulo c v y se ve es un ángulo central
y como es el ángulo central
correspondiente a este ángulo inscrito
de 48 mide el doble es decir mide 96
grados lo voy a marcar por aquí este
ángulo de acá me de 96 grados excelente
ahora vamos a utilizar que el ángulo ha
circunscrito como te dije eso quiere
decir que los rayos que forman el ángulo
son tangentes al círculo y notemos que
aquí este rayo llega al punto ce y como
tenemos que siempre el radio que llega
al punto de tangencia es perpendicular a
la tangente entonces este ángulo de acá
es de 90 grados de manera similar
tenemos que v
es un ángulo de 90 grados otra vez
tenemos este radio que llega al punto de
tangencia entonces es perpendicular a la
tangente muy bien y con esto seguramente
te darás cuenta de algo de algo muy
interesante tenemos el cuadrilátero c
en donde conocemos la medida de tres de
sus ángulos y además sabemos que en un
cuadrilátero la simple suma de los
ángulos internos siempre es de 360
grados entonces eso nos permite plantear
una ecuación la voy a escribir de este
lado tenemos que 90 grados más 90 grados
90 grados más 90 grados más 96 grados
más 90 96 grados más la medida del
ángulo en a más la medida del ángulo en
a es igual a 360 grados 360 grados eso
es la suma de los ángulos internos de un
cuadrilátero podemos restar 180 de ambos
lados y otra forma de escribir esto es
que 96 grados 96 grados más la medida
del ángulo en nada
la medida del ángulo en a es igual a 180
grados para 180 grados muy bien esto lo
que nos está diciendo básicamente es que
el ángulo c/v y el ángulo c a b son
suplementarios bueno pues para encontrar
la medida del ángulo en a la medida lo
voy a poner más para que la medida del
ángulo en a simplemente restamos 96 de
ambos lados y obtenemos que la medida
del ángulo a es igual a 80 a 84 grados